foreign
to a special edition of FYI looking at
the Amazing Life Of Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II
when Buckingham Palace announced that
the queen had died you'll have noticed
flags on official buildings flying at
half mast
radio stations playing respectful music
TV stations changing their schedules and
for many of us life has slowed down even
stopped
this is because as a nation we've
entered a period of mourning
while the royal family are coming to
terms with the loss of a mother
grandmother and great-grandmother
they're also mourning the loss of their
Queen
and they invite us to unite with them
because of course she was our queen as
well
Braden looks back at the life of our
longest reigning head of state
[Music]
princess Elizabeth was just 25 years old
when she became Queen Elizabeth II the
39th Sovereign to be crowned
the coronation made television history
as it was the first ever to be on TV
Her Majesty's placed on the throne came
sooner than anyone expected although it
was a very joyful occasion her journey
from Princess to Queen was a difficult
one
[Music]
Elizabeth Alexandra Mary Windsor was
born in 1926. her parents were Prince
Albert the Duke of York and Lady
Elizabeth Boles Leon
her family called her Lily bat when she
was young she loved horses and got her
first Pony for her fourth birthday
Elizabeth and her younger sister played
games ruined the piano and dressed up
for plays like other children of the
time
but the princesses didn't go to school
they had lessons at home
laughs
a last tribute to a great king a great
and honored man the father of an Empire
when her grandfather King George V died
in January 1936 his son Edward who was
Elizabeth's Uncle became king or he
didn't stay in the job for long
a few hours ago
I discharged my last Duty
as king and Emperor
Edward wanted to marry an American woman
Wallace Simpson who had already been
married and divorced but in those days
that just wasn't allowed in the royal
family so Edward chose love over Duty
Edward stepped down from the job of king
and the crown was passed to his younger
brother Albert Elizabeth's father Albert
adopted his father's name and became
King George VI and now Elizabeth was
unexpectedly next in line to the throne
foreign
[Music]
broke out in September 1939 many
children were evacuated to safety but
not the princess
when Elizabeth was 14 she gave her first
speech on the radio she sent her best
wishes to children who had been
evacuated from the cities to the safety
of the countryside
country have had to leave your home and
be separated from your fathers and
mothers
My Sister Margaret Rose and I feel so
much for you as we know from experience
what it means to be away from those we
love most of all
it is just because we are not forgetting
you that I want to send you our love and
best wishes to you and to your kind
hosts as well when she turned 18 she
begged her father to allow her to take
part in the war effort eventually he
allowed her to train as a mechanic and
military truck driver she Remains the
only female member of the royal family
to serve in the military
[Music]
at 21 Elizabeth had fallen in love she
married the Duke of Edinburgh on
November 20th 1947 in Westminster Abbey
in the early 1950s the king's Health was
not good when Elizabeth was just 25 her
father King George VI died and her life
would change forever
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign's role was mainly ceremonial
representing our country abroad and
hosting foreign leaders as a democracy
we elect a government to make the big
decisions
she was also head of the Commonwealth an
association of countries that sign up to
creating peace and prosperity
made up mainly of the countries that
used to be ruled by Britain
Elizabeth remained queen of 16 of those
countries including the UK
the Queen's war was mainly to support
the Nations she ruled a role she took
very seriously supporting hundreds of
Charities and organizations
even though the queen could never
interfere with how the country is run
every week she discussed government
business with the prime minister
those meetings took place with a total
of 14 prime ministers
from Winston Churchill to Boris Johnson
[Music]
and just before she died she met the new
prime minister at least Tross
Her Majesty received about 60 000
letters every year can you imagine
receiving that much post
and many people know that the Queen's
favorite dogs were corgis
she owned more than 30 throughout her
lifetime
[Music]
family was extremely important to the
queen
as well as having four of her own
children and she leaves behind eight
grandchildren and twelve
great-grandchildren
in our lives Mr President we have seen
the worst but also the best of our
continent instead of retiring what most
people do the queen continued to work
although she cut down a bit on her
official duties and engagements she
never stopped meeting with politicians
or the prime minister of the time to
keep across how the country is being run
I declare before you all
but my whole life whether it be long or
short
be devoted to your service
and the service of our great Imperial
family to which we all belong
[Music]
although she was one of the most famous
people in the world the queen was a very
private person who kept her opinions to
herself
her position as head of state was
largely symbolic and our elected
government has the real power but while
politicians come and go the royal family
keeps alive a sense of history that
attracts millions of tourists and the
queen was dedicated to supporting her
country any way she could
some FYI viewers wanted to have their
say on why the queen was so important to
them
I love the fact that Queen Elizabeth was
able to keep with traditions in the
royal family but also adapt with the
times of society and she was able to
introduce laws on saying that princesses
could be put above princes in the line
to the throne if their aid permitted it
the average retirement age is 65
and she served the country for years
after that and had remained mentally and
physically active to carry out her
duties I personally think that that's
amazing I remember there was one time
during the Olympic ceremony where they
pretended that the queen jumped out of a
helicopter and I think it's little
things like that that just goes to show
that the queen is going to be remembered
by so many different things so not just
being the queen and having a
responsibility but also humorous points
such as that you know even every year
with her Christmas messages that was
something that would always bring a
smile to everyone's faces no matter what
was going on but I wish you a very happy
Christmas from stepping up to the
biggest and hardest job in the world age
27 she's never stepped the foot out of
line something that I will always
remember about Queen was when William
and Kate got married she was there on
the balcony smiling as a grandmother she
was really proud and it was really nice
to see that you know on TV that Not only
was he a queen but she was also
grandmother and she was talking with
everyone I think it was really sweet
[Music]
some of us might be upset that the queen
has died even though we didn't know her
or have even met her
's fyi's counselor Anna Williamson on
why we may be feeling the way we do hi
hi
so why are so many of us upset when we
didn't even know her
so if it does feel a bit strange to you
that you're feeling sad about the queen
passing away because you never really
met her and if anyone says to you well
that's strange you know you shouldn't be
feeling those feelings because you
didn't know her
um that's false it doesn't mean that you
can't feel emotion we can feel emotion
as a country we can also feed off other
people's emotion around us so if someone
else is feeling sad if our whole country
is feeling sad then you know what we
probably will be feeling a little bit
sad as well so it is a sad time and it's
important to remember that when someone
dies when someone passes away it's
important to process how those feelings
are and just to sit with them give
yourself time give yourself kindness and
do whatever it makes you feel content in
processing those so if you want to talk
about the queen if you want to ask
questions about the queen do it ask it
from people that that you care about and
that know you and just be reassured that
however you are feeling right now is
perfectly perfectly okay
for most of us we only saw the queen on
TV or a passing Glimpse while standing
in a crowd but what was it like to
properly meet the queen
[Music]
well the queen was coming to the Science
Museum that day it was a new exhibition
called top secret it had like codes Moss
code machines the queen was also writing
her first ever Instagram post and
posting it but it was so funny because
her phone was connected to this big
screen so everyone in that entire Hall
could just see what she was writing and
when before we met the queen we did a
really fun coding exercise we couldn't
different lights that would if we moved
away get darker if we move towards it
lighter and then that's actually what we
showed the queen and it was really funny
because whenever anybody came up the
stairs we would all smarten up sit up
straight and think it was the queen and
it happened about 10 times before she
actually came in no I think it was like
15. yeah when the queen finally came we
were like oh it's just gonna be like
another camera person yeah we didn't get
ready we sort of like just slumped down
like in our chairs like oh it's fine
nothing's gonna happen
but then the queen walked in with like
five bodyguards behind her in front of
her and we were like oh oh just
sometimes we suddenly did it through
that yesterday
when the queen came over
um she asked us like a couple of
questions like
um how does it work and one of them was
um if she could have a go
and I tried it out herself which is
really really cool yeah like she held
what we were holding at that moment you
could see a separate side to the queen
she didn't seem above us all in a way
she didn't act as though she was like
VIP she's very humble
[Music]
the queen was visiting Quorum it was
their 350th birthday Quorum is a charity
what helps young people who don't have a
mum and dad and luckily I was like the
lucky person to actually talk to her and
hand her a book and it was really
exciting I was going to London and it
was quite fun she's the most important
person in the world because she's a
queen of England and queen of a lot of
other countries as well
before I met the crew and I was feeling
anxious about like messing it up I was
practicing giving my book to my mum
pretending she was the queen and asking
her questions my first impression was I
thought she would be much taller but she
wasn't she was only this big
I thought she was going to be quite
formal but she was really chatty and
sweet and like a little Nan
the question I asked with queen is what
was your favorite country out of
everywhere you've been to she said I've
been to too many places I cannot
possibly say she was a bit nervous to
say a country because people be alike
that's not fair
a lot of people have not met the queen
and there was like an important thing I
was so excited and happy and shocked she
was actually there
as the most well-traveled monarch in the
world the queen represented Britain in
visits to 117 different countries flying
the equivalent to 42 times around the
globe but she never actually needed a
passport she was the queen after all
home and abroad she supported over 600
Charities and organizations and was the
first to do the famous Royal Walkabout
we leave you with images of her
incredible life bye
[Applause]
[Music]